if a person cannot control their body
then we're not truly living in a free
society my name is Mary Beth Blakey I'm
a volunteer clinic escort for patients
accessing reproductive health care when
we greet a patient we prioritize being
very calm and introducing ourselves and
saying I'm a volunteer for the clinic
there are protesters here today so I'm
here to walk you to the door so that
you're not harassed
it can get very very loud a lot of
protesters will bring noise amplifiers
loud speakers they can play sermons they
play sounds of babies crying on a loop
they try tactics that appear that are
very passive-aggressive that that can
appear gentle but are really meant to
shame people and are really meant to hit
people in a very vulnerable spot you
know calling the patient's mother's
calling the support people father's have
mercy on your baby and the Lord will
have mercy on you and they try to make
them believe what the procedure is not
safe they try to tell them about you
know oh woman women have died here this
doctor cuts women up any emotional
manipulation tactic that they can use to
get someone not to go in that door
patients that are targeted by abortion
restrictions are overwhelmingly
low-income patients patients of color
patients who may be undocumented they
may struggle to get their appointment
funded they may struggle to travel to
their appointment there needs to be more
clinics and those clinics need to be
accessible there is no right to abortion
without access to abortion so there's so
much more work that still needs to be
done